he has a duffel bag filled with guns
from what I know he's a schizophrenic I
don't understand how he was able to buy
a duffel bag full of guns yeah let alone
one gun exactly your dad goes to be a
nice guy to help your mom's mom move
yeah a schizophrenic Uncle walks out
fires two rounds in the U-Haul hits your
dad and then the police show up and he's
like nah that grabs a shotgun
and they they just wipe his ass out
honestly like from my point of view I
think it was that was his plan in the
first place was to have some type of
moment so have cops come and my dad gets
into being the victim towards this is
exactly why you don't help people move
right here
the Honeydew with y'all subscribe today
[Music]